oh my god Chandler Bing my Snivy from
India my name is Satya Navarro I am from
Mexico City Mexico I'm from Berlin
Germany
I'm from Scotland from New Zealand I'm
from Israel I'm from London England I'm
from Saigon Vietnam and this is my
attempt at the American accent since my
husband is from Michigan I decided I
would do a Midwestern accent last time I
went out with Brad he spilled Faygo and
better made chips all over me at the
Tigers game my name is Tim you can call
me mitt it's backwards for Tim and
meanness or I and all those people up
there I love hockey man and I was like
oh yeah I love hockey too I love me some
good when skansen changed power I'm from
a medpor and I say words like aluminum
and stone color without the youth I
literally love bacon bacon is love it is
everything okay so let's go back home to
New York we like it over here Brooklyn
is in the house so the last time I was
in New York I was with a friend of mine
called Joe you know he looked at me and
said hey forget about it all right
already
can't get out of here let's go to the
store to get some coffee I would like a
Dunkin Donuts are you doing my name is
Mike I'm from Jersey you want to go over
to Manhattan maybe get a slice some
coffee
I don't know forget about it hey walk in
here I think my favorite American accent
to do is the southern accent just
because I like the way that they talk in
the way that pronounced yet the words to
me these southern accent sounds
like this I am gonna chew tobacco all
night long
who's insane to myself jump on the horse
cowboy and doing you'll be missed
hey thermia me you all seem a little bit
loss and I thought that calming help oh
hey y'all I'm from Alabama I live with
my grandma and my dog my my dog my I
could not do a New York accent
so we do California and your eyebrows
are like calm sleep is that the word he
was just really hot and like I don't
know whatever like we just hooked up
what's the big deal
Josh's myself a boyfriend totally hot
six-pack abs but Jake Josh he's like so
poor doesn't have any money
like Josh get your act together find a
sub presence here it's no small things
in our lives that keep us rolling and
keep us going we gotta know how to
appreciate those things all right most
of the content we watch that's films and
sitcoms are American this is just for
how we think you guys talk so no hard
feelings and peace out I think of the
Midwest
I think of tornadoes and a big Dust Bowl
and people doing absolutely nothing at
all every single Indian who goes down to
a maritime that comes back comes back
talking like this so yeah yeah yeah best
of luck to you guys